hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the google edition htc one now the
regular htc one was one of my favorite
phones of this entire year i gave it the
number one choice in my top five 1080p
smartphones it's just a brilliant phone
altogether but now that there's a google
edition of this phone it's time to take
a look at what sets this thing apart
what makes the google edition phone
worthy or different from the regular htc
ones without any further ado let's take
a closer look at the google edition htc
one this device on the outside is
basically exactly the same as the
regular htc one you simply cannot tell
the difference because well there is no
difference the google edition one only
comes in the silver 32 gigabyte model
and everything that was great about the
build quality of the regular htc one is
still great about the google edition one
as well the aluminum body the slight
curves the front facing speakers the
zero gap technology the front and back
facing cameras the sealed and battery
even the beats audio logo which we'll
get to in a second all of that stuff is
the same on this phone and up till now i
could have been showing you a regular
htc one and you would have never known
but the real difference comes as soon as
you turn on the phone because as you
know the google edition htc one is
running a stock build of pure android
the regular htc one is just getting the
android 4.2 update now with htc sense
but this google edition phone comes out
of the box with the latest version of
android 4.2.2 and we'll get all the os
updates right behind nexus devices very
early which is great so all the
differences that make this different
from the regular htc one are in the
software department so we'll go ahead
and take a look at those first of all
there are actually a new boot animation
for the google play edition phones this
isn't a nexus boot animation right now
this is only found in the google play
edition htc one and galaxy s4 so that's
pretty cool that that's new now yes this
is booting into pure aosp stock android
vanilla android pure android however you
want to put it that is what comes on
board so no htc sense skin no carrier
installed apps no bloatware just pure
android because there's no htc stuff you
actually do get some nice bonuses like
uh that non-expandable storage space you
get more of it free out of the box and
you get slightly better battery life
with less blink feed and other htc stuff
running in the background so other
things have changed too first of all i
found this rom to be overall a bit
snappier when compared to htc sense 5
and since 5 was already really fast on
the regular one i think that's to be
expected though by now with aosp it's
just naturally a bit snappier and more
fluid overall and that's even more
apparent with the google edition galaxy
s4 when you compare it to touchwiz and i
also think that stock android happens to
look really pretty on the black bezel
around the display i just wish i could
get a black google edition htc one since
i think that would look even sexier now
of course htc sense isn't all bad in
fact some of the htc ones hardware
specifically depended on optimizations
from sense to be good the speaker and
the camera now the speakers are already
huge but like i mentioned earlier the
google edition one still has a beats
audio logo on the back and you're
actually going to find in the sound
settings a beats audio toggle so this
device still has a dedicated separate
audio amplifier inside for those massive
speaker drivers and they've chosen to
continue to label it beats audio whether
or not you decide to use it is up to you
have a listen to the difference in the
sound it makes
awesome
so beats audio is still in full effect
here and i just leave it on all the time
to avoid all the suppressions that come
with turning it off i'll leave my beats
audio explained video in the description
below that like button if you're looking
for any more information on that now as
far as the camera goes this is still
htc's 4 megapixel ultra pixel camera i
didn't explain video on this too so i'll
link that below but basically because
this only takes 4 megapixel shots htc
had quite a few algorithms and tweaks in
sense five for some sharpening and some
optimization for low light performance
to make this look better in regular
light after spending a lot of time with
the device and looking at the photos
i've taken it looks like a lot of these
optimizations are still present turns
out they're not all completely built
into htc sense but they're built into
the imaging chip that is still part of
the google edition one's hardware like
the beats audio amplifier so it comes
with the new google camera software
interface and swipe gestures to change
settings and everything but the images
you'll be able to take will look exactly
the same so you'll be able to switch to
video mode take hdr shots panoramas and
photo spheres etc with google software
and it'll have the same quality as a
regular htc one so of course you're
going to be missing all of htc's extra
little camera features like zoe and the
effects and live filters but overall it
is very fast and definitely not a bad
quick point and shoot camera for just
the regular photo taking experience so i
think it's pretty obvious by now i
really like stock android i like the way
it looks and i prefer it over sense in
just the way it operates and i like how
quick and responsive it is on hardware
that it's optimized for and this google
edition isn't just a regular htc one
with pure android on top of it it
actually has quite a few tweaks and
adjustments behind the scenes to make it
work for the one the button layout is a
good example on the bottom it's not on
screen buttons but you do get to have to
long press the home button to get to
google now and double tap it to get to
multitasking and that back button is
always a back button so no menu button
down there you still have to use on
screen menu button but nothing else
switches about that the bottom line here
is it works it has all of those
delicious hardware specs that make the
htc one the flagship of the year for htc
minus that infrared port so at the end
of the day i really like the google
edition htc one there were some initial
concerns about whether or not stock
android would run fine on it but like we
said there are some
little behind the scenes improvements to
stock android that make this run really
well on the one it's not a nexus
obviously because of those you know
hardware button layouts and it's
slightly different because there's no
on-screen buttons but i figured this
would be a good chance to take a look at
what
native stock android basically would
look like on a phone when it's not
cyanogenmod or anything like that now
you can also download a google edition
from for your htc one if you have one so
i'll include the links below to any of
that stuff if you want to check it out
if you're daring enough to root and
flash something like that but uh yeah at
the end of the day it's a great phone
and i'm a fan i'm gonna be recommending
it to a lot of people who like stock
android either way thanks for watching
this quick video be free to stay tuned
because the google edition galaxy s4
review is also in the works that'll be
coming up very soon either way thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
you